[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER CROSBIE:
Hey, everybody.
I'm Christopher Crosbie.
I'm a partner engineer
here at Google Cloud.
So what that means is that I
help our partners in the data
and analytics space,
such as Hortonworks here,
either build, move, or integrate
their products onto the Google
Cloud Platform.
And I'm actually really
excited of be here.
Because before I came
to Google and was
partnered with
Hortonworks, I was actually
a Hortonworks customer.
I was a data science
manager at a large cancer
institution in New York City.
And when we were there, we had
this really great enterprise
data warehouse.
The data in it
was just pristine.
Everything that was
supposed to join together,
joined together, hundreds of
ETL processes ran every night.
We had workflows that
could go through and make
sure the data got corrected
when errors were found.
However, what we found was
we would build these models
off that data.
We'd have these great AUC
curves and everything.
But then when we went
to actually put those
into production or put those
into an actual workflow,
they fell apart on us.
And that's because the data
that we actually had access to
in real time was very different
than that pristine data
warehouse data.
What we had in real time,
that data was on structure.
It was tons of duplicates.
It was riddled with errors.
So what we did is we
worked with Hortonworks.
We set up a small
Hadoop environment
where we could
start collecting all
of those various
transactional messages
that were flying around the
hospital during the day.
And so with that, we can
start building our models
on top of those data structures
with the goal of, hopefully,
giving us much more
accurate models,
because it was based on data
that actually represented
what was available.
So it's been a lot
of fun for me to,
first, be on that customer
side of Hortonworks.
But now, to be
partnered with them
and getting to take a peek a
little bit behind the curtain,
and see how this product
is actually developed.
So hopefully, with
today's session,
I can give you some
of those insights too.
So here's an overview
of what we're
going to talk about today.
So first of all, I
just set up where
we are with the Google and
Hortonworks partnership today.
And then I'm going to lift the
hood a little bit on Google
Cloud Storage and
how that integrates
with Hadoop and a couple
of differentiators
you should know
about if you're used
to working with other objects
stores and Google Cloud
Storage.
Then I'm going to
hand off to Sid,
one of the principal
engineers at Hortonworks,
who's going to give you an
overview of hybrid environments
in enterprise security,
as well as give you
very prescriptive guidance for
how you should be deploying
Hortonworks on Google Cloud.
And then, finally, Jon, product
manager from Hortonworks,
has an awesome demo with
Cloudbreak on Google Cloud.
So you definitely want
to stick around for that.
So to get started, where we
are with our partnership.
Hortonworks and Google Cloud
accelerates Next gen Big Data
in the Cloud.
All right, so obviously that's
a line that came to me directly
from the marketing folks.
But what does this
actually mean?
What this means is more options
for hybrid Hadoop deployments,
as well as extending
your enterprise
applications into the cloud.
So the way this is
actually done is the GCS--
the Google Cloud Storage--
connector for Hadoop
is now integrated into
the Hortonworks platform,
and it's fully supported.
Hortonworks data HDP as
well as Hortonworks data HDF
are both fully compatible with
the Google Cloud platform,
integrated, and supported.
So what does this actually
mean to you as a customer?
What features can you expect?
Well, you can definitely
expect more agility and ability
to run a femoral HDP workload.
You should also be expecting to
maintain those same enterprise
applications and extend
them into the cloud.
So more specifically, things
like your metadata management
tools, you should be able to
take those and extend that
into the cloud.
You no longer to have to break
your data lineage if something
goes into the cloud.
Same thing with your security
and compliance models.
Those are going to
be consistent now
between on-prem and the cloud.
So you don't have to necessarily
go through and redevelop
and reaudit everything
for security.
Now, we're going to talk about
some of the caveats with that
later.
Sid's going to address that.
But in general, you'll be able
to take those same paradigms
and move those to the cloud.
And of course, all of this is
going to be 100% open source.
Both Google and
Hortonworks are very
aligned in terms of making sure
that we are contributing back
to the open source community.
So both the GCS connector
as well as Hortonworks
are committed to making
this 100% open source.
So before we get to the
new Hortonworks model,
just to level set, I
do want to talk briefly
about something that's existed
in the cloud for a while.
And this is the
Google Cloud Storage.
This can be used alongside
HDFS, the Hadoop file system,
to separate your storage
from your computer.
You can make this your
persistent storage layer.
And the advantage
of this is now,
you can start to scope
your clusters to the job.
So instead of spending a lot
of time building these Spark
configurations to send to a
multi-purpose cluster that's
going to then go compete for
resources, what you can do
with things, like
Cloud Dataproc,
is if you have a machine
learning-heavy job, you spin
out a compute heavy cluster.
Send your machine
learning job to that.
If you have interactive
analysis job--
so things like Hive, or you
want to have a BI layer--
that can just be a
memory-heavy cluster,
and you send jobs to that.
And Dataproc has
a lot of features,
such as workflow templates,
that will help you build these.
And we have customers, like
our friends at Spotify labs,
who actually create
a framework, called
Sypdra, that sits on top
of Dataproc that will also
help you dynamically
size these jobs.
But with this
Hortonworks partnership,
what we are really
able to do now
is we can start to mix
and match entire Hadoop
distributions, along with
the job sizing as well.
And so that architecture,
it's really powerful.
And if you use it
correctly, this
is also going to be a
big cost saver as well.
So the idea here is
that now, pointing all
to the same source of
data, your HDP users--
so those folks who have spent
the last five years learning
Ambari and are happy with it, or
your data analysts that really
like working in the Hive
web interface with Pez,
and they want to keep all of
that, all those enterprise
features--
they can simply move
that to the cloud.
However, as you are
finding some jobs that
maybe don't require a lot of
those enterprise features,
you can spin that.
Nightly ETL jobs is a
good example of that.
You could start
to spin those off
into short-lived Dataproc
clusters and save some money.
Also, because all the compute
and storage is decoupled,
you can have more
experimental clusters.
Maybe your data engineer
or your data science team,
they want to start experimenting
with Spark 2.3 on Kubernetes.
They can still be pointing
the same data sets
that all your enterprise
HDP users are using.
Now, I think it is worth
taking a quick pause.
Because we talked
a lot about, hey,
just use these cloud storage
mechanisms instead of HDFS.
But I think its worth a pause
to talk about what is actually
happening.
Because there are
some changes that take
place, especially in
the security layer,
as you make these changes.
And it's worth understanding
what's happening and why.
The GCS connector, it's
kind of a misnomer.
But it's not actually
pulling data into HDFS.
It is, at the block level
and over Google's very high
performing network, just
directly accessing that data.
And so Hadoop has this abstract
notion of a file system
of which HDFS is just
one implementation.
You can also use GCS, S3A,
and various other systems.
This was originally
designed by the folks
who were developing Hadoop.
It was pretty fortuitous
the way they did this.
When you're working
with big data,
you want to be able to have
block sizes of it, like,
64 gig.
But you don't want that
limited just to one
disk on one machine.
So you extract that away.
You just deal with
the blocks of data.
And so that works great for
both HDFS as well as GCS
However, what that does mean
is a lot of that metadata
information at the file
system level, that's
net storage subsystem,
and that doesn't
go into the Hadoop layer.
So that's important, again, for
some security considerations.
Meaning you have things,
like Apache Ranger.
It's not always the easiest
idea, or the best idea
just to slap that
onto GCS storage,
because that really
relies on HDFS
permissions and some
positive compliance things.
But we definitely do want
to learn more about how
this connector works because
there's a lot of benefits
to using this storage
connector, even
though some of the
security paradigms change.
So for instance, as
we just talked about,
you get that direct data access.
This is not just
pulling data into HDFS.
This is actually pulling
blocks of data over Google's
high performance network.
However, even with that
direct data access,
you're still going to get
your HDFS compatibility.
All your jobs are
going to work the same.
You just need to change the
prefix of some of your files
from HDFS to GS, and you
should be off and running.
But with that
compatibility, you're
also going to get a lot
of cloud interoperability.
So it makes it
very easy when you
have this separated
persistence storage layer
to move from Hadoop to Spark
to even other Google Cloud
Services.
So it's really a great
gateway for getting
into some of these more
interesting higher level
Google services, like BigQuery.
So I was working with
a e-commerce company.
And their pattern is they start
with all of their log data.
That's sequential output.
And they would just run
straight MapReduce on that.
Then that data, they start
to analyze with Spark,
and turn that into these
business data marts.
This is mostly from
marketing analytics,
so it's things like their
campaigns, their per customer
use of the data.
And then they store
that in Google BigQuery,
and that becomes pretty much
their enterprise data warehouse
where their data
analysts can use
it to understand
the business better,
put their Tableau dashboards and
things like that on top of it.
And so this is all possible
because of the data
accessibility.
So when you shut down
a Hadoop cluster,
you're going to lose
access to all that data
that's sitting in HDFS.
It's really tied to
these spinning disks.
That's not true with
Google Cloud Storage.
It's separated, so
your applications
can still access that data,
even where you Hadoop cluster
isn't running.
And of course, even
though it is accessible,
it's also highly available.
And this is done without
much of a performance flaw.
But the really cool thing
about both the accessibility
and the availability is there's
really no storage management
overhead on your part.
So anybody that's
administrating HDFS today
knows the pain points of
running checks on that data,
upgrading versions,
doing rollbacks.
That kind of work is done.
Except with Cloud Storage,
it's done by the Google Site
Reliability Engineering team.
It's not something
that your team is going
to have to carry a pager for.
So it really helps
with that overhead.
You're also going to
get quick startup.
So typically, with
HDFS, you don't
get to start running jobs
until your name node comes out
of safe mode.
With Google Cloud
Storage, as soon
as your workers come online, you
can start to access that data
and process that data.
And a lot of customers that
we're working with, over time,
have told us that
that's cost saving
because Google Cloud
is something that
builds at the per second level.
So if you're talking
about minutes every time
a femoral cluster comes
up for a specific job,
over time, that's going to be
a significant cost reduction
for that quick startup.
You're not going to be paying
for the inefficiencies of start
up costs.
And then finally, you get
integrated into the Google
Cloud Security ecosystem.
And you'll get to take advantage
of all the cloud security.
But again, I definitely
want to point out
this is great that
it gets you in there.
But you want to be aware of
the changes that do occur,
because they're a different
storage subsystem,
and you're going to have to
manage these different storage
subsystems HDFS in
Google Cloud Storage
a little bit different thing.
So a couple of quick tips
for working with Google Cloud
Storage.
You definitely want
to be taking advantage
of our different
storage classes of GCS.
Other object stores
that you might
be accustomed to working
with, they have separate API
calls, where if I put
something into an archive
or cold storage, I have
to call a separate API,
restore the in four hours.
All three of the storage
classes are the same API calls,
same system.
Your jobs will work the same
between regional storage
or nearline storage.
It's just a matter of
where you put them.
So regional storage, that
comes in two flavors--
multi-regional or regional-- and
this is where most of your data
is going to live.
This is what you're going to
use for your interactive Hive
or Spark analysis.
And the rule of thumb
here is, basically,
any batch job that will
occur more than once a month.
Now nearline storage
is the next tier down.
And this is really
for batch jobs
that you're going to use
for historical reporting
or aggregation.
Rule of thumb here
is, if you're going
to touch data
about once a month,
this is nearline storage.
And then finally,
coldline storage
comes into place for that
post-process data, stuff
you probably don't think
you're going to use again.
But you want to keep
it around just in case,
or maybe you have compliance
reasons to keep it around.
Rule of thumb
there, if you think
you're going to touch it once
a year or less, coldline.
Now, next tip is,
don't be afraid to use
GCS as a destination.
So GCS-- Google Cloud Storage--
we provide strong
global consistency
for a lot of those operations
that are relevant to Hadoop--
read after write, read
after metadata update,
read after delete, bucket
listing, object listing.
So some other object store
you may have worked with,
they're eventually consistent.
So to get around
that with Hadoop,
you have to build some kind
of glitchy architectures,
where you might have
a NoSQL database that
sits in between the object
store and Hadoop that's
going to keep track of what
the files are actually doing,
what's available.
For the most part, that
all goes away with GCS.
You can just use it
as the destination.
Now there's a couple
of outlier cases
there, such as a
rename [INAUDIBLE]..
But what our customers have
told us that for the most part,
it works fine.
For the vast majority
of use cases,
they use GCS as a destination.
So if you want to get
started with this,
you can try it in pretty much
any Apache, Hadoop system
that you have.
All you have to do is
drop a single JAR file
into the classpath.
And you can pull that JAR
right off of our GitHub repo.
Starting to release 1.9.
It's going to work with
both Hadoop 2.0 and 3.0.
And then you just have to
configure the permissions.
So if you're in Google Cloud
Storage or Google Cloud itself,
definitely take advantage
of service account for this.
That will give you that
transparent token exchange.
But if you're coming from
on-prem or a different cloud,
go ahead and you can
set those credentials
in the core-site file.
So with that, I'm
going to hand it over
to Sid, who's going to talk
more about hybrid environments
and enterprise security.
SIDDARTH SETH: Thanks, Chris.
I'm Siddharth Seth.
I work as an engineer
at Hortonworks.
I've been associated with a
bunch of Hadoop projects--
Hive, [INAUDIBLE],, YARN, MLApp,
for about seven years now.
So before getting
started, I'd just
like to set some context
on hybrid environments
as well as security, which will
be useful later on in the talk.
So first off is the
Hortonworks Data Plane service.
This service lets you
manage your on-prem as well
as cloud clusters in
a single environment.
It gives you a view of
all of these clusters.
The Data Plane
platform itself lets
you run services on top of it.
And that's really where
you get the value.
Some of these services are
the Data Steward Studio,
the Data Lifecycle Manager,
which are already available.
And what's coming soon is
the Data Analytics Studio,
Cloudbreak.
And it's possible for
additional services
to be added to
the same platform.
The Data Plane platform
provides an interface
to access these clusters as
well as user management and role
management for the services.
So DSS and DLM are two services
which I'll talk about today.
DSS lets you manage your
data sets, whether they are
on-prem or on cloud storage.
You can view the data sets.
You can view access patterns.
It comes with a view which lets
you look at audit information
to see who has accessed
the patterns on the data.
It also comes with
a few profilers.
A very interesting one is
sensitive data, or PII data,
profiler which can scan
through your data sets.
Essentially, it can go
and tag sensitive data
at a column level or at
a data set level, which
then integrates later on
with Atlas and Ranger,
and we'll come to that.
DLM is the data
lifecycle manager.
It's responsible for data
and metadata replication.
So it lets you replicate data
between on-prem as well as
cloud environments.
It also serves as a
disaster recovery solution.
Because it's replicating
both the data,
metadata associated with, let's
say [INAUDIBLE],, as well as
your Ranger or audit policies
or any security policies
which you have in Ranger.
It's great that we can
run Hadoop clusters.
If you look at very
simple Hadoop clusters,
you have storage,
and you have compute.
Very often, that's not
enough for enterprises.
It's great that they
can run their jobs.
But enterprises require
governance and security
in place.
Towards this, there's
several components.
There's Knox, which serves
as perimeter security.
Especially in
cloud environments,
you don't necessarily want
to expose all of your points
over the public cloud.
Knox secures all of
these public end points.
The Hive metastore, of course,
has metadata about your tables
and data, in general.
And we'll talk a little bit
more about Ranger and Atlas.
For people who haven't used
these products already,
Ranger gives you authorization
policies for your data.
So this can be, let's
say, at a database level,
at a table level.
In addition to that,
what's very important
here is it gives you
fine-grained access control.
So you can actually go and
say that a certain column is
sensitive data, flag
that, and set up
a policy to say that
only certain individuals
or certain organizations
have access to this data.
If someone else were to
try to access the data,
the data ends up getting lost
while running a Hive query.
Another piece over here
is tag-based policies.
And we'll come to that when we
put all these systems together.
Apache Atlas is for governance.
So this keeps track
of data lineage
as well as data classification.
So when you generate
a new data set,
you'll be able to say
what the source data
sets were to get to this data.
That information
is always tracked.
Atlas also is integrated
within most parts of the Hadoop
ecosystem.
And it has APIs for integrating
with external components.
In case you have an
external data source,
and you're bringing
data from that,
it has APIs to
integrate with that.
Now, putting all
of this together--
DSS, Ranger, and
Atlas-- you could end up
saying the DSS sensitive
data profiler runs
to tag sensitive data on
all of your data sets.
That then sets up tags in
Atlas, or you could manually
set up tags in Atlas.
And after that, you set
up policies in Ranger
saying that any data
with this specific tag
is only accessible to users who
are authorized to use the data.
And this provides a
very powerful attraction
for the entire security
mechanism of securing your data
and making sure you
have an audit trail.
Ranger takes care of the audit
for all of your data access.
So that results in that
context for the rest
of the presentation.
So deployment
architectures of the cloud
is what we'll talk about next.
This is a diagram of your
typical on-prem deployment.
Now, these are typically
long-running clusters.
They are shared
by multiple users.
Resource management is
handled by YARN queues.
Different organizations can end
up sharing the same cluster.
They'll have allocations
within YARN queues.
This cluster is secure,
will typically be secure.
You'll have authentication in
place that's like your l-dot.
Kerberos will be in place.
Data sets in HDFS.
Temporary data is called
out separately over here.
It sits on the same HDFS.
It's called out
separately because we're
going to iterate on
the site further down.
There's a metastore.
There's Ranger, Atlas.
Atlas isn't explicitly
called out here.
But there's Ranger, Atlas
in place for your security
and governance.
Very important here is also that
this cluster is long-running.
It needs to be reliable.
All the musters are
highly available.
This is a simplification of
the same diagram which we'll
iterate upon further down.
Again, data and temp data
here are the same HDFS.
They're just called out, so that
we can iterate on this diagram.
As a first step, it's very
tempting to kind of say, OK,
I have an architecture on-prem.
Let me just take the same
thing-- previsions VMs
on the cloud and run the same
architecture on the cloud
with data setting on HDFS.
Now while, in theory, it's
simple to reason about,
it's not really the
best way forward.
The main problems here are,
one, is data setting on HDFS?
Which means you can't really
scale your cluster that way.
When HDFS is replicated,
if you remove enough nodes,
you will end up losing data.
Ultimately, you can
use persistent disks,
and then you'll have to
deal with reattaching disks
when you scale up or
scale down the cluster.
So it's not necessarily
the best mechanism to use
when migrating to the cloud.
All right, moving on to
some cloud deployment
portals which can be used.
You need to start thinking
a little differently when
moving from one kind of cloud.
All of these deployment
architectures
serve different use
cases and can be used.
The first one here
is very simple--
an ephemeral cluster.
The pieces in the red outline
are optional components.
So your first step is to say,
I'm going to have compute.
I have a temporary HDFS only for
temporary data on the cluster.
And the main storage
goes to GCS over here.
And then this system,
Hadoop security is optional.
You can, instead, rely
upon cloud security, which
includes IM network
security rules to make sure
only certain people have
access to the system.
There's no metadata.
When you get started, you
can attach a metastore to it
if you want.
You can attach Ranger
policies at a later point.
But you end up redefining the
same thing over and over again.
It's great for ad-hoc jobs.
Moving on is where we
introduce shared services.
So at this point, what we're
doing is we take the metadata,
and we split the cluster data
into two different entities.
We have a shared services
cluster, which, at this point,
becomes a long-running system.
It's always on.
Other clusters will be launched
and then attached to this.
Again, in this model,
Hadoop security is optional.
It's very similar
to the previous one.
The metadata sits in GCS.
The advantage we get over here
is that the metadata is always
available.
It's easy to discover data.
You can attach as many
clusters as you want.
And all of them will
see all of the metadata
and will be able to access
the data via GCS itself.
If you do want authorization,
you will, again,
define a new Ranger and Atlas.
And you will connect to that.
But you will have to
redefine your policies.
Now this is a system
which works really well.
A use case of this would be
development of environments.
As an example, in
Hortonworks, this
is used extensively,
where we've pre-generated
some data sets on GCS.
The metadata is
sitting in cloud SQL.
And we attached a
metastore to it.
And whenever we need
to try out new code,
do some testing, et cetera,
we spin out a new cluster,
do the testing, do
the experiments,
tear it down to save costs.
So taking this to
the next level,
then, this is where we get into
the enterprise security space.
We're going to move Ranger
also into this shared services
cluster as well as Atlas.
Again, it's not
called out over here.
But Ranger and Atlas now moving
to the shared services cluster.
It's long-running.
A very important
distinction here
is that Hadoop's security
becomes an important aspect.
There's not a lot of point in
doing authorization if you're
not authenticating the users.
So data sits in GCS.
Connect as many
clusters as you want.
Spin up new clusters.
They'll have their
policies available.
They'll have the
metadata available.
All the performance
optimizations
which come with
the metadata will
be available on this cluster.
OK, so just a recap of
the shared services.
This is essentially
what your system
will end up looking like.
There's going to be one
long-running shared services
cluster.
It's plugged in with your l-dot.
It's plugged in with Kerberos.
You can attach as many
ephemeral clusters
as you want to
launch jobs, or you
can have long-running clusters
utilizing the same metadata,
same policies.
Long-running cluster,
this is completely up
to the way organizations want to
structure their Hadoop systems.
An example of a
long-running cluster
would be an analytic cluster
which is serving dashboards.
You don't necessarily
want to spin that down,
because it's
serving a dashboard.
So you just attach
the same cluster,
have your policy enforcement,
have you metadata, all of that
managed via this.
Now this is where you really
get the agility of the cloud
while you get
capacity on demand.
So if on-prem, for
instance, you've
run out of capacity on
your Hadoop deployment,
it takes a long time to
get new servers in place.
A lot of organizations don't
even want to get new servers.
You would just provision a few
more instances on Google Cloud,
and you have new capacity.
The other big advantage here
is you can leave your existing
workloads running.
You may have pipelines
already in place.
Some stable workloads
are on a schedule.
But you want to try out
newer versions of software.
You may have Spark 2.3, or
a newer version of Hive,
newer version of Spark.
You can just launch
a separate cluster,
which will attach, again, to the
same shared services cluster.
Play with it.
Once you are happy with it,
you will migrate the production
environment over to this.
Similarly, you can set up test
instances against the same.
Another paradigm is lift
and shift for data on GCS.
This is a very feasible option.
Something you should
keep in mind--
there's very few HDFS nodes,
so it's easy to scale.
The other thing to keep in mind
over is if it's multi-tenet,
a single long-running job can
prevent scaling of the cluster
because there is intermittent
data which cannot be lost.
Otherwise, a job will have
to end up [INAUDIBLE] status.
OK, so this talks
about the cluster
shapes, irrespective
of whether it's
a shared service cluster,
ephemeral cluster,
or long-running clusters.
There's master nodes.
There are nodes which run
a temporarily HDFS as well
as double S compute.
And then there are
compute-only nodes.
Depending on the
kind of performance
you want for your
workloads, you would
run all of these on
non-preemptible VMs.
And to save costs,
you can always
wrong the compute-only nodes
on initial preemptible VMs.
Hadoop knows how to recover
jobs in case nodes go away.
And it will take care
of all of this for you.
This talks about the
various Google Cloud
components which are used.
HDP, HDF will run on
Google Compute Engine.
Ingest-- you will bring
your data into GCS.
You write your data out to GCS.
The shared services
cluster, you use Cloud SQL
for Ranger and the metastore.
And the shared services
cluster, again,
runs on Google Compute Engine.
Logging and monitoring can
be integrated into the shared
services cluster.
Part of the logging
and monitoring
would go in over here, where
we have metrics via Ambari.
The other part-- systems
logs-- could go in
through Google Cloud
logging infrastructure.
All right, so covering
some recommendations
which are very specific
to Google Cloud.
Something to keep in mind
is that this performance
scales with the size of the
disk up to a certain point.
So size your disks accordingly.
Also very important
is attached disks.
Google offers local SSDs and
a couple of attached disks,
either spindles or SSDs.
But attached disks count
toward network traffic.
In fact, they count
towards, depending
on the type of
attached disks, it
will either be 3x of the actual
data being written or 6x,
depending on whether it's
[INAUDIBLE] original.
So that's something
to be aware of.
And this will compete
with the actual jobs
running on the cluster.
Shuffle data is,
essentially, data
which is transferred between
tasks during a running job.
This is data which, if it's
lost, it doesn't matter.
Because again,
Hadoop run times know
how to regenerate this data.
If this data is small
enough, for best performance,
locally attached SSDs
is the way to go,
because you would not be
competing on the network
bandwidth.
This data is typically for a
job transferred, in any case,
between nodes.
And there's no real reason to
put it onto attached disks.
Another important point is to
configure independent disks.
Because if a certain
disk goes bad,
Hadoop knows to just remove
it and continue running
with the remaining disks.
Temporary HDFS could be a few
standard persistent disks.
Again, it's temporary.
You don't really care too much.
All it's got is crash
directories, intermittent data,
things like that.
LLAP he provides interactive
performance with Hive.
It knows how to cache data.
It caches data at
the column level.
It doesn't cache entire files.
It can either do this
in memory or on disk.
So given the performance
characteristics
of the various disks available,
local SSDs is the way to go.
The one difference here is
combine these SSDs together,
because it will work
with only a single disk.
And combine them
together and configure
LLAP to use that as the cache.
And this can make a pretty
big performance difference
when running.
Because it's got
the data already
fetched from cloud storage.
It's got the specific
columns pre-fetched.
It's got metadata about the
information in the cache.
GCS is running in
the same region.
That's pretty much the most
important thing over here.
You don't necessarily
need to run it.
You don't want to be accessing
data across regions with GCS.
In terms of the
network configuration,
the bandwidth on a node is
linked to the number of cores.
So that's something to keep in
mind while sizing your nodes.
The workers typically
need higher bandwidth,
so you would want
more CPUs over there.
We already covered that
persistent disk count
towards the network limit.
So configure things accordingly.
Google offers a standard network
tier as well as a premium tier.
For Hadoop profiles,
most of the traffic
is within the cluster itself.
The standard network tier
is more than adequate.
And very important is
you use private IPs
within cluster traffic.
You do not want this
going to public IPs.
One, it's an extra hub.
Two, it also costs more.
In terms of node
sizing, this is not
very specific recommendations.
There's plenty of
information available on how
to size your nodes.
This just talks about the
flexibility on Google Cloud.
So one thing to keep in mind
is that the cost for CPUs
scales linearly.
So you can size your
nodes accordingly.
There's high mem nodes.
There's dedicated
nodes, if required.
The other bit here is
sustained use and committed use
discounts.
Now the committed use discount
here is very important.
So how it works in Google is
you pay up front for CPU cores
rather than instant types.
And at a later point, you can
decide how to use these cores.
You can define
different instance types
based on these cores.
Master nodes, especially
in the ephemeral clusters,
do not need to be the
biggest nodes in the cluster.
You don't need fewer components.
It's absolutely fine
to size them smaller.
In terms of cluster
operations and maintenance,
ephemeral clusters are
meant to be short-running.
They wouldn't be
highly available.
You don't need them
to be upgradeable.
What you're going to do instead
is if you need an upgrade,
throw away your old cluster.
Spin up a new one.
On the other hand, the shared
services cluster is always on.
All the ephemeral clusters
and long-running clusters
attach to this.
So you want this to
be highly available.
It has to be upgradeable.
It has to support
running upgrades.
Putting all this together--
Cloudbreak 2.7, which is
offered by Hortonworks,
supports shared
services and lets
you spin up these environments.
HDP 2.6.5, as well as 3.0.0,
offers GCS connectivity.
That's how you can
play with this.
At this point, I'll
hand it over to Jon
to talk about Cloudbreak.
JON DYBIK: Thank you.
Thanks, Sid.
So I'm going to talk
about Cloudbreak today.
And this is really about, how
do we pull everything we've
talked about today together?
We've talked about Google
Cloud Storage, shared service
architecture with ephemeral
workloads in the cloud.
But how do we actually
get to the cloud?
How do we get these
workloads and start
performing big data workloads
on Google Cloud platform?
And that's really
what Cloudbreak does.
It's all about
provisioning workloads
and pulling in a lot
of best practices
and prescriptive
guidance into the way
that you provision these
workloads onto Google Cloud
Platform.
So if we could actually
switch over to the demo.
Great.
The best way to really
talk about Cloudbreak
is to show it live in action.
So I'm going to do
a live demo today--
fingers crossed here--
and kind of walk
through how you provision
HDP and HDF workloads
onto Google Cloud Platform.
So the first thing I
want to point out here
is I have a data lake shared
services cluster provision,
just like Sid talked about.
This is an architecture where
we're externalizing a Hive
metastore data.
We're externalizing audit
policies and audit logging
from the cluster itself
into this shared services
architecture.
And this is something
that Cloudbreak support.
So I've pre-created a data
lake shared services cluster.
You can see here,
I have a couple
of external sources set up.
I have my Hive metastore, as
well as my Ranger database
and audit logging,
externalized from the clusters
that I'm going to deploy.
So that's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to walk through
creating a new cluster.
And show you how easy it is to
deploy HDP onto Google Cloud
Platform as well as attach
that to a shared services
architecture.
Quite simply, I'll click
Create Cluster up here.
And I could choose
the data lake that I
want to attach it to to get
all those shared services,
as I spin up these
workloads on demand.
So I'll choose my
data lake cluster 3.
And my credentials--
so these are
credentials that are pre-set
up in Google Cloud Platform.
This is what allows me to
instantiate instances on GCP
as well as get HDP
deployed on GCP.
So let's give this a name.
We'll call it Demo 3.
Choose my particular
region here.
I'm going to stick
with the US East one.
The platform I
want to deployment,
whether that's HDP 2.6, whether
that's 3.0, or HDFS as well.
So let's choose a
data science workload.
Right out of the box, Cloudbreak
includes several blueprints.
So if you're familiar
with Ambari blueprints,
you'll be familiar with
Cloudbreak blueprints.
And this essentially lets you
define the component services
and configuration of
those components that
are going to be deployed
in your HDP cluster.
So you can see we
have three here.
One for data science,
an EDW workload, and ETN
workloads as well, with the
common components that we get
deployed for those workloads.
So let's go ahead and
choose data science.
We'll click Next.
I'm actually going to
do the advanced UI,
now that I think about it.
We have a basic and advanced UI.
The basic UI is really
good to get you up
and running very quickly.
The advanced UI, if you're
going to use the UI,
is going to be what
most enterprises would
do to get all the customizations
that they want set up as they
provision workloads.
So my image settings here, I'm
going to use the base image
settings that we ship.
You can actually create
your own custom images.
So if you have your own
corporate enterprise standards
for images for some of the Linux
distributions that we support,
you can certainly
build those images
and deploy your corporate
standard images gold standards.
I'm going to use the
out-of-the-box images we have.
Hardware and
storage-- so this is
where I can make some
adjustments to my host groups.
We have a master node, as
you can see at the far right.
This is going to be my
Ambari server as well.
And we have worker nodes and
compute nodes host groups.
And I can come in
here and adjust
any of the sizes for them.
With volumes-- the
number of instances
that I'm going to deploy
for compute nodes here.
Let's say we add an instance
here and deploy one instance.
And we've heard a lot
about cloud storage today.
That's integrated with
Cloudbreak and, obviously, HDP.
To do some cloud
storage here, I'm
going to have to put
in my service account.
And let's put in my
base storage location.
And then we could attach
this to the Hive warehouse
using Google Cloud Storage.
So cluster extensions,
again, we give you
very prescriptive
guidance in Cloudbreak
on how to get these
workloads up and running.
But we understand, again,
just like custom images,
there's customizations
that you're probably
going to need to make.
So we have this concept
of recipes here.
This allows you to
run shell scripts.
And you can determine at
what point during the cluster
installation that these
scripts are going to run.
Is it pre-Ambari
being installed?
Is it post-Ambari
Is it actually a
recipe that runs
when you terminate the
cluster and remove it,
as you would ephemeral
workloads when there's
no longer a need for it?
But again, these recipes allow
you to run shell scripts.
And an example of
that would be if you
needed to join your host to
an active directory domain.
So you do all the work for that
up front via Ambari install.
And then when you
terminate the cluster,
there's probably some
active directory cleanup
work that you need to
do, and you could have
a recipe run at that point.
All right, let's go next and
talk about external sources.
And this is a new capability
we launched in Cloudbreak 2.7
is the notion of
dynamic blueprints.
So very likely,
instead of the need
to create one-off blueprints
for several different
configurations
that you need, you
could have a single
blueprint and inject settings
into that blueprint.
So you can do things like
one-time configurations.
Common would be if you
want to connect these
to an l-dot directory and do
things, like single sign on.
I have an l-dot directory set
up here, an active directory.
You can configure this to
connect to external databases.
These are probably one-time
configuration settings
that you want to set up and just
be able to easily select those.
Next.
Now during configuration, Sid
talked a little bit about Knox.
We have that ability to
provision with Cloudbreak
and wrap your clusters
with an Apache Knox powered
secured gateway.
This is great for limiting
surface area of ports that
are exposed to the
public internet
and really securing the
services that you want
to publish for your cluster.
So we can do that right here.
Very prescriptive
guidance, we can wrap that.
Then we get to the
network configuration.
We can select existing
networks and subnets
we want to attach to.
We need to make
sure, in this case,
because we're attaching to a
data lake services cluster,
that whatever selected network
and subnet you have defined
can communicate with the shared
services cluster as well.
You can come in here and
edit the security groups.
You can create a
new security group,
edit your existing
security groups.
We intelligently know what
services you want to deploy.
So we're exposing
the correct ports
needed for that,
like 9.4.4.3.22,
and 9.4.4.3 for
Cloudbreak communication
with the cluster, and 8.4.4.3,
and port 22 for SSH as well.
And some last security
configurations
that I need to do.
Give my Ambari admin a
password and put in my SSH key,
so I can show into the boxes.
We did support Kerberos as well.
You can enable Kerberos.
If you want to do that, there
are some prerequisite checks
that you need to go through
to make sure that's set up
for your environment correctly.
If you're just
doing some testing
and getting up with
Cloudbreak really quick
to see how easy it is to
spin up workloads or try
some workloads on your own,
you can use a test KDC.
We use an MIT KDC.
But again, this is only
suitable for a test environment,
not suitable for production.
You should bring your own KDC.
And then, very simply,
create cluster.
You can see my new cluster
being created here.
Depending upon how many nodes
you're deploying and whatnot,
it usually takes
about 20 minutes here
to get through a complete
cluster deployment, instantiate
all the VM Instances as well
as do the Ambari install,
and then add all the nodes
to the cluster as well.
When it's done, your
cluster is going
to look similar to this one
that I've already created
and attached to my data lake.
You can see here, here's
the gateway configuration
with all the endpoints
for all the services
that I published
through Apache Knox.
I can see all my external
sources that are attached
as well as the cloud
storage that I have attached
to this particular cluster.
One popular feature for our
customers is auto scaling.
So once they get on the cloud--
and I'm working with
ephemeral workloads--
I can actually
resize this workload
and add additional
compute nodes.
I can add additional
worker nodes manually.
But auto scaling is a
great advanced feature here
that we have that allows you
to scale up and down based
on different events
that happened.
So for example here,
we have alerts.
And that's the basic
from which you're
going to create policies that
are going to happen here.
And alerts can be time-based.
They're based on
Cron Expression.
So at particular
times during the day,
if you want to grow the workload
that you have to provision
on the Cloud, or you
need to shrink it--
let's say it's a batch job or
something that runs at night,
and you need to
scale up for that--
you could certainly
do that based on time.
You can also do that based on
any Ambari metrics as well.
So based on what
you see going on
in that cluster, if you need
to grow or contract and whatnot
and take advantage of
elasticity in the cloud,
you can certainly do that.
And then from the auto
scaling policy's perspective,
again, you can add nodes.
You can remove nodes.
You can also set
the number of nodes
to a particular number
of nodes that you want.
And then you define
which host group
that this policy applies to.
All right, great.
So that's it for
the demonstration.
Just one thing I want
to mention real quick,
and then we'll go to questions.
We got some time for questions.
We do have a booth.
It's on the third floor.
If you're coming
from the escalators,
it's all the way straight back.
It's facing the stairs.
So come check us
out at the booth.
We can demos for you, talk
about any of the products
that we have, and then answer
any questions that you have.
So thank you very
much for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]